eric fenney now in the rotation with
steven strasburg going to have surgery
on that wrist this will be his third
start his sixth appearance a one-on-one
record a 2.55 era so runner at third
base and two down jt romuto is the
batter and the pitch swinging a high
pop-up shallow right eaton coming in
and toward the line and adam eaton makes
the catch jake arietta gets the baseball
for the fills a 1-3 record of 495 era
had a couple of decent starts early but
has struggled with his command bottom of
the first hitting no score trey turner
set to lead off
and turner makes a loud noise to right
center
see
you
later
home run number six of the season now
it's an 11 game hitting streak and he's
reached in 17 games in a row and the
nationals have the lead
bang
zoom goes trey turner it's the nationals
one of the phillies nothing
top of the second inning philly's trail
one nothing it'll be d d gregorius gene
segura alec baum
eighth year in the big leagues for
gregorius
and the only guy over there is the nat
shortstop and trey turner almost air
mailed one
good grab by azruvo cabrera and he made
the tag
finance will have runners on the corners
for carter kibum
to the left side
cut off by segura there's one quickly
over to first in time how about that
quinn to 41 average on the year the
starter in center field tonight
garcia
pops up and throws right on target
and that will bring up
andrew mccutchen one out one on
that one's lined out towards center
field that's going to drop in for a base
hit kingry to the third he's being waved
home the throw to the plate offline he
scores standing and the phillies tie it
up at one
so to god here's jt real muto here's the
1-1
and it's swung on hit in the air right
field pretty deep going back he's eaten
to the track nearing the wall he jumps
and it hits the top of the wall and now
goes over it bounds into the nats
bullpen
and jt real mutual with just enough to
get it over the right field wall for a
three-run home run
it's his ninth of the year and the
phillies take a four to one lead
here's scott kengray who
smoked a double off the left center
field wall last inning
this time he does not run and the 3-2 is
in there for strike three call starting
to get a little rain falling
misting rain
and
kind of steady missed crowd screws
stands at the ready
batteries eric thames
you can hear the rain now pitter patter
that's more than
a mist
here's a swing by eric thames and a
ground ball right side into the overship
booted by kingry on the outfield grass
and thames will be aboard
carter keyboom the batter here is a
swing of the ground ball hit right head
short this will be two gregorius to the
back he'll fire it to first it's in time
and another double play second one for
kibum tonight third for arietta no runs
no hits and error and nobody left we're
through five
it's official phillies four then that's
one so the game stopped officially at 7
27 into a rain delay after five innings
with the phillies leading by the score
of four to one back at nationals park
we're just about ready for the
resumption after a rain delay of a
little over an hour and 10 minutes
alec bowman is over two he's grounded
into a double plays flat out to right
the 1-1 swing a long drive to center
chasing this one roblox this one way
back he leaps and he makes a terrific
catch segura was around second he heads
back to first robles throwing that
direction double play
on the fly
are you kidding me
rowley's a scintillating catch on the
warning track
doubles off segura with a throw to first
on the fly
that one is almost impossible to believe
here's adam eaton who is lined out to
center and
grounded back to the pitcher
and a meeting launches one that's out of
here if it's fair
see
you
later
adam eaton hits his second home run in
his many nights in his third of the year
he draws the nationals a run closer it's
now the phillies four the nationals too
bring up andrew mccutchen row blaze is
shaded a step or two to right
bouncer left side coming home is turner
the throw to the plate roman quinn safe
at home plate he got to the back end of
the plate
and has he slid perfectly this year
5-2 phillies on top
jt real muto the philly's all-star
catcher whose three-run homer
is the big blow in this game it came in
the third inning it's on the way
swinging a miss so one out of runner at
second in the rookie the designated
hitter tonight for the phillies
alec balm is the batter
the pitch
swinging a bouncing ball towards the
middle it's through a base hit into
center field around third deedy will
score and alec balm with an rbi single
to center has increased to philly's lead
it's now six to two
well bowm is in scoring position there's
two down and kingery
is the batter he's one for three in this
game with a double his first extra base
hit of the season
now the pitch swung on and the fastballs
popped up shallow right center
garcia out and calling he's camped under
it back pedals a step and makes the
catch well he's half the lead six to two
juan soto the
best man of this lineup to try to get
the nationals back in it here's the kick
in the pitch swinging a chop off the
plate bounds out towards the infield
segura cuts it off fires to first and
it's in time great play
by gene segura here is gene segura
who's two for four tonight
faces loaded ball hits sharply into
right center field to base it one run is
in rounding third and heading for home
is bryce he'll score two run single for
segora it's his third hit of the night
it's 8-2 phillies attic is one for four
tonight
adam eaton has this one tailing back to
him
long top of the night phillies pick up a
couple
over shift now for eric thames
parker kicks and delivers swing in a
line drive one up and it skips through
hoskins and down the right field line
cabrera has scored thames on his way to
second he'll pull in there without a
play
and it's eight to three here's carter
keyboard walks
apartment grounded into a double play
grounded into a double play and popped a
shallow center
ground ball third base gobbled up by
segura hesitates a moment throws to
first in time
and the phillies win it